des cerises des pommes mais aussi des
bananes des kiwi et des nchis à Guill
encour le jardin exotique de angfo a des
alure de jungle
miniature unou chinois
aussi deux fois par an la jardinière
organise les portes ouvertes au grand
bonheur des amateurs de nature quand
vous faites Cu après les feu devient jus
dev
violet ah
ou c'est la prière fois que je viens
visiter ce jardin je j'ai toujours voulu
ça fait des années que je veux venir et
c'est enfin cette année j'ai réussi à me
décider et ce que je découvre c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus grand que ce que je
pouvais imaginer pour moi c'est une
cohabitation de d'arbres et de plantes
parce que tout se mélange et tout est
libre on a l'impression que les plantes
se sentent bien ça c'est fantastique
c'est vrai on l'impression que
elle cohabite très bien il y a pas de
plan de mal
elles sont toutes en bonne santé enfin
c'est super quoi néo Laos an défaut est
arrivé en France pour ses études elle
vivait en appartement et c'était la
naissance de ses enfants qu'elle a
choisi d'avoir un peu de verdure 800 m
car à entretenir alors qu'elle
découvrait le jardinage les grosses
bêtises que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
j'ai planté les pommes de terre avec qui
qui ont germé et j'ai mis les germes à
l'extérieur je crois que c'est ce sont
des germes qui qui vont qui vont sortir
de la de la Terre et qui vont qui vont
fleurir et quand mes voisins ont vu ça
ils m'ont ils sont venus me voir dit non
c'est pas comme ça il faut faire il faut
les
enterrer angf est aussi responsable du
groupe des Jardiniers de France sur 50
ans en iveline un groupe qui compte une
centaine d'adhérents et qui organise
atelier échange de plantes et conférence
tout au long de
l'année